hey youtubers is Charlie so season six
is over season seven hype watch has
begun this is just gonna be a general
guide for like the video games expand
the material that you guys can check out
in the off season till we get to
comic-con we get some new material in
that first trailer so just careful for
spoilers from season six if you haven't
watched season six yet that should be
the first thing that you do right now go
watch season six but there's a whole
bunch of other Game of Thrones stuff
that you can do in addition to reading
the books or listening to the audio
books that's usually the first thing you
would tell someone to do but because
season six officially move past the
books and pretty much everyone's
storyline that's not as easy to do
especially if you've already gone back
and reread the books a couple times if
you are a big book person George R
Martin does post sample chapters from
winds of winter on his blog you can read
the tales of duck and egg that's
basically three books that they've now
collected in a single compendium called
a night of the Seven Kingdoms it's
really good it's like the leading
candidate for a game of Thrones TV
spin-off of HBO decides to do that
there's the dance of the Dragons which
is like this really big historical
Targaryen Civil War that takes place in
a couple different short stories that
he's published called the princess and
the Queen and then he wrote a prequel to
that later called the rogue Prince if
you're really big history buff and you
kind of want to read a book that's in a
wiki form world of Ice and Fire is a lot
of fun it has a lot of illustrations in
it george RR martin also contributed a
lot of material for it he didn't write
it all himself though lands of ice and
fire is a really awesome map's book for
planet toast that's what the planet is
called in Game of Thrones it's not
called Earth that's just called Planet
O's but it has maps of cities it has
maps of continents it's been around for
a while and if you're not a big book
person but you like play games there's
all the tabletop games those were some
of the first things like the card game
was one of the first things that they
created for Game of Thrones when George
R Martin started writing the novels
there's a lot of tabletop RPGs that
they've released expansions for as he's
published new novels and then there are
the straight-up video games but I would
recommend you stick to the telltale
narrative games the other games aren't
so great telltale games are pretty good
but the story of those games is not the
story of the TV show it just involves
some of the same characters it takes
place in the same universe so it is in
continuity it references things like Jon
Snow is part of the game Kit Harington
did the voice
Emilia Clarke Peter Dinklage like a
bunch of people did voices from the TV
show for their characters in the game
but the story itself isn't something
that you're gonna see on TV and then
finally like the biggest thing that you
should all really get hype about is
comic-con this year that's really when
they're gonna be releasing actual new
content for the TV show and they could
take it a couple different ways but
unlike last year like if you watch the
Game of Thrones panel from last year at
comic-con it was almost like a non-event
like you could definitely tell they were
trying to hide the fact that they knew
Kit Harington would be coming back like
Jon Snow would be resurrected but they
couldn't tell anyone about it so they
couldn't bring him and they kind of had
to tiptoe around the thing that everyone
was talking about like what the hell
happened to Jon Snow is he dead is he
coming back sorry I'm glad that people
were upset that he died it would have
been I think my biggest fear was that
people were gonna be we're not gonna
care or it'd just be fine Jon Snow's
dead but it seemed like people did have
a a similar to the red wedding episode
of kind of grief about it which meant
that was something something I'm doing
the show is doing for Jon is right so
that is without a doubt probably like
the most boring game of Thrones
comic-con panel that they've ever had
this year is completely different they
don't have to hide anything it's all
about the suspense of the battle between
Cersei and Daenerys what's going on with
Jon Snow getting ready for the night
king so they can talk about all that
stuff
they've already revealed where White
Walkers come from how the children of
the force created them so there's really
there's not that many secrets that are
left to keep so they could probably
answer almost any question and if you
haven't seen it I've already done a
video about Jon Snow's father HBO has
kind of unofficially well maybe maybe
officially come out and confirm that so
what are they going to bring to Comic
Con in addition to the actors they you
know they've announced like five or six
of the main cast that are coming but
usually they bring the blooper reel
which is kind of an odd thing I mean
it's fun but it's not really new content
and in the past they have brought
casting reels for new big characters
they're bringing on but because we're in
the later seasons there aren't that many
new characters that they're casting but
if you're wondering about
Baylor's or footage from the next season
like they've barely even started to work
on the new season so they probably won't
have any footage to show off from season
7 but they will be teasing things
telling funny stories for behind the
scenes clarifying story points like
what's going on with Sansa is she really
jealous of Jon Snow like what's gonna be
the drama in the northern storyline it's
pretty clear what's going to be
happening between Cersei engineers
they're basically gonna have like a
queen bowl like you had the snow bowl up
in the north like the bastard Bowl now
we're gonna have the Queen bowl down in
the Crown lands so there's all kinds of
stuff you can do to pass the time before
the next season gets here and if you're
wondering about winds of winter the book
that's like the thing on the tip of
everyone's tongue is like when is it
coming George R Martin hasn't really
said anything official but a lot of
people are feeling like it's gonna be
January that's like the latest rumor
that I've heard January 2017 so I'm
expecting that it will drop before
season 7 and because the show is so much
different from the books now you could
actually read it and feel like it's new
content even though they've largely
moved past that on the TV show like the
really big things that George R Martin
was hyping for winds of winter was the
Battle of Winterfell which we saw that
was basically the bastard Bowl and then
the second siege of murine which they
kind of brushed over in a single episode
on the TV show ooh and I almost forgot
if you are a big convention person next
year like right around this time like
during this weekend next year in 2017
there's going to be a con of Thrones
which is basically a game of Thrones
specific convention that will be taking
place in Nashville so they actually have
a website it's just con of Thrones so
I'm sure they'll be making announcements
about actors and panels like things
they'll be doing it that next year I'm
not exactly sure how big it will be but
if you've ever been to one of the
smaller comic book conventions I'm
expecting it to be that but it'll be
just Game of Thrones specific it'll only
be about Game of Thrones things but let
me know in the comments what is your
guys favorite thing to do between Game
of Thrones seasons to get ready or past
the time for the next season usually
like it's really fun to do bonus videos
each week and we will have Comic Con so
we'll actually have some information
about next season in a couple weeks and
then if you're new to my channel like
last year all through the fall in the
winter we had all this news about
characters that were coming on so when
you start learning about that you can
start making guesses about what the
seasons going to be doing is actually a
lot of fun and if you weren't sure yes
I'm totally going to be doing bonus
videos every week
till we get to season seven so there's
anything specifically you guys want to
talk about it's like the holiday weekend
right now so it's pretty quiet I think
my next video will probably be azor Ahai
because they were doing a lot of fun
things playing with the idea that maybe
Daenerys is the one who was promised no
wait maybe Jon Snow's the one who was
promised so we can talk about how the TV
show is messing with us in my next bonus
video we should post in like a couple
days I'll probably do a Q&A this week
too so feel free to leave any questions
that you guys want me to include in that
and there is a new round of the giveaway
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card I
will still be doing the Game of Thrones
giveaway each week during the off season
so I know it feels like season seven is
a long ways away but there's gonna be a
lot of Game of Thrones in the off season
later tonight I'm gonna be posting an
attack on Titan Season 2 video they
finally announced that's gonna drop next
spring so get hype for that while you
guys wait for me to post that video you
can click here to learn a little bit
more about Jon Snow's father and you can
click here for all my season 6 videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you